and this actually lead us to the next
topic which is in domain versus outdoor
domain what we would like in general is
outer dimensionalization what we have
usually is in the main channel is Asia
what does it mean let's have a look
we've trained our model on question
answering data sets now we are
experimenting with like real life where
question answering is different like the
domain is different the language people
use is not Wikipedia language and we see
there is a strong performance drop
because our model is not really capable
of out of dimensionalization here is
another nice example on this paper by
thomas mccoy and we show that actually
if you try and birds and has good
performances unlike your fine tuning
that's a set i glue okay you can then
expand then test it on another data set
which is out of domain so how they did
out of the main is here is by having
some heuristics so for instance you try
to make like for instance lexical
overlap heuristics
so in Amendola you have two examples and
you have two sentence and you have to
say if one entail the other or
contradict the other okay they are very
simple heuristics for that in the data
set which mean that usually if there is
not means contradiction if there is a
lot of flexible overlap it means you the
entailment so they build an adversarial
data set called the hands which is in
the transformers library actually you
can use it we have an example it and
which is adversarial so when there is a
lot in this data set enhance where there
is a lot of lexical overlap its
contradiction the good label is
contraction here is an example here and
when they show that is that they can
train several birds on this fine tune it
with different random seed okay so the
differences is very small the difference
between this model is very small it's
just the weightiness ization of the last
layer and this model they behaved
similarly on aminal i
they have like various very similar
performances but when you test them on
the adversarial hunts that I set they
behave really differently okay there are
this huge variability some of them are
pretty good well none of them is really
really great but some of them are not so
bad some of them are really bad and this
means that actually what you see in
domain to test performances you see just
give you no indication of how your model
will behave in the real world which is
kind of bad okay
here is more example than what they do
on them in a lie their values heuristics
they use to design and you can see you
have more or less variability in the
fine-tuned model some heuristics leads
to like really huge variance which means
that you can't really know how your
mother will behave in the real world
unless you be able to honest you able to
test it on real world that's huh and so
I'm I like small app smaller effect okay
now it's really hard to investigate out
of the metallization so one way is to do
this kind of heuristics another way is
try to build our datasets ourselves so
we can control them so the only really
interesting Philips in this work is the
work and compositionality composition I
teach to investigate how you model is
actually able to combine values part of
a sentence to build a meaning
representation this is very important
because we think that in linguistics
composition is something important that
we do when I say the blue dog is going
out you kind of gather blue and dog
together in a single in a single meaning
and then you combine this with the rest
of the sentence to build up the meaning
so there's a nice work called scan and
pcfg sets which was actually a really
really long but super interesting paper
by age of two up kiss from Amsterdam
University and they can build a huge
data set that replicates some natural
language data sets so they be status in
which you you have to combine
instruction together to generate an
output okay and you have to combine
instruction compositionality so you
generally nice output so ever you have
like it's written like repeat something
and the something will have to be
considered as a single entity and then
the repeat function at the apply on it
and they were able to naturalize the
data set so they were going to reproduce
the depth and the length of like a
translation or a very big translation
that i said the VNC challenge okay so
they're this artificial data set you
generate this instruction yourself but
which really replicates well natural
language and when you have these
artificial deaths that you can actually
do some out of the man generalization so
for instance in your training part you
can remove some instruction some words
do the model will never see them or like
some way to combine words and it can get
how the model will learn to do that and
then like one of the most fascinating
experiments have so last year which is
called over generalization over the
duration is like super fascinating it's
it's a bit like when you're when you're
kid you're learning language and you
make mistakes but these mistakes are
like smart mistakes okay
for instance you will add Edie at the
end of a past verb a verb in the past
tense but it's like an irregular verb we
say instead of saying I went we say I go
with okay and this is called smart
mistake because it means you've learned
room you've just not learned yet the
exception and we really want our model
to learn rules so they can generalize
outside of the training domain okay so
you can investigate that by putting some
irregular verbs in this article that
said so here you can investigate that
and the nice thing about these paper is
that they compared the complete various
architectural they compared lsdm they
compared kind of nets they compared
transformer together what they see is
the really very important C's like Alice
then they cannot struggle with this
question of over memory of over
dollarization
and transformer are really a lot better
you can cornetist somewhere in the
middle so this is this nice graph where
you see on the top you have like very
few examples like a very few exception
so it's kind of hard for the model to
learn that so here you see during the
training
the red means that the model is over
generalizing the blue means that the
model has lone exception and the gray
mean that the model actually don't
really know what to do so it's
predicting like random output which is
neither the rule nazar expected the
exception and when you have only a very
few sample like very few exception
although just can't really get them
cornet managed a little bit to do that
but transformer and elastic they don't
when you have a lot of exception the
model learned just to memorize them that
would we see in your network okay they
are very good at memorizing brute force
memorization and when you were in the
middle you see a bit something that's
similar to the way human learn which is
much you start to have over the
ionization during your training you're
the peak when you actually
overgeneralize everywhere and then you
learn that there are some exception so
it's very interesting and it shows that
this model are capable of some out of
the main generalizations now talking
about in domain and out of the
mineralisation posed the question of how
do you measure the distance between your
two domains and that's a very open
question there is a large body of work
on domain adaptation let us try to show
that you can actually extract some
feature from your data set and you can
compute some similarity metrics on them
but it's definitely a very open question
how can you measure the distance like in
a statistical meaning or you can measure
the distance between two data sets okay
now you can know when you're not in
domain anymore